like Beauty standard really is something
that's created by Society like at some
point
um you know like we only saw women with
fairer skin blonde hair blue eyes as the
beauty standard for a long time
why delude yourself about the society in
which you live in you don't live in that
Society where women are who are fat yeah
are the beauty of something you don't
live in that Society just because I
don't live in it doesn't mean I can't
acknowledge it no no I acknowledge it
too but that's my point is that we lived
a society
that is proof that beauty standards
really are just created they're
subjective exactly but the one in which
you live in lightly though just convince
herself that she is a uh whatever it's
like in this society's beauty standards
you ain't that mighty